comment allez vous messieurs dames je
suis excité pourquoi car c'est une vidéo
sponsorisés toutes ces heures passées à
faire de la poterie la pâte à modeler
des origamis des sculptures en ballon
mon permis d'atteindre aujourd'hui le
sponsor dans une vidéo activités
manuelles n'est pas dire que je suis pas
doué avec mes mains mes amis aujourd'hui
à parler de lego lego c'est beau c'est
mythique tout le monde connaît vous
savez voilà j'ai dit on va faire un
format hybride un format de vidéo qui
est l'enfant
certains de deux autres formats le sobre
et 10 et la vidéo activités manuelles
ces deux formats se sont accouplés pour
donner celui d'aujourd'hui la vidéo
seul manuel je viens de l'inventer je
suis fier de moi je vous le dit direct
alors en première partie de vidéos on va
aller sur un seul président qui
s'appelle les goûts je vous ai dit la
fanbase légaux elle est énorme à tel
point que les mecs partage des tas de
trucs sont assombries dit et que c'est
un sommet dit très très actif vous savez
à quel point j'adore découvrir le talent
d'autres gens que ce soit des gens qui
décident des gens qui peinent des gens
qui sont forts en gymnastique des gens
qui bref j'adore voir le talent des gens
et quand ce talent est lié à quelque
chose de manuels qui l'a fait avec ses
mains ça m'impressionne encore plus sûr
c'est abusé là en ce moment je regardais
truc de souffleur de verre
ça me rend dingue c'est tellement fort
et en seconde partie de vidéos nous
irons pour la partie activité manuelle
avant nouveau studio que vous avez vu
est une surprise nous y attend une très
grosse surprise nous y attend et on va
construire aussi deux trois trucs mais a
déjà un truc est construit qu'ayew jh je
me suis pas ce vol je les ai pas vus il
ya un drap dessus j'ai hâte de soulever
ce drive de découvrir nous avait
habitués aux lego c'est à ce pack là
l'aspect au studio ces genres sans quoi
ça je vous dit personnellement j'adore
légaux je dis pas que j'en ai fait
beaucoup mais en tout cas j'ai un gros
respect pour cette marque passe pour moi
c'est un peu comme minecraft qui
pourtant est un jeu vidéo ça pousse les
gens à être créatif et je trouve ça
super est ce qu'on peut dire que les
gosses et minecraft irl puisque je suis
une affreuse personnes qui de n'importe
quoi respectez au moins de vue déjà le
sobre et dit oh la la
voilà typiquement ce dont je parle les
fans de lego moi vous savez j'adore le
modélisme les gens qui construisent des
petites maquettes dans leur sous-sol
dans leur pièce cachée secrète j'adore
ça les fans de lego c'est un autre game
regardez moi cette organisation de toute
ma vie je me suis jamais organisé comme
ça pour quoi que ce soit chaque boîte
correspond à certaines
pièces de lego ranger dans un ordre
précis
[Musique]
voilà il ya cent cinquante mille pièces
de lego là et 200 l'aide
il a mis 6 mois apparemment à construire
ça et je trouve ça fou dette aussi
patient quoi prêter moi un peu de votre
patience clément pour un anniversaire il
m'a offert les ss en lego je vous
rappelle la date de mon anniversaire le
27 janvier
j'ai toujours pas trouvé courage mon
fils de 10 ans voulait me partager sa
création avec vous tous il l'a nommé le
robot cassé ses bons mots il ya de la
poésie dans sa création il a quel âge
disant basse en train de m'énerver tout
simplement non mais regardez moi comme
cela peut être quand tu n'as pas assez
d'argent mais tu as assez de lego mec
devient ingénieur faire un truc il m'a
agacé lui aussi [ __ ] c'est là où l'ego
ils ont été trop fort ils n'ont pas
acheté leur réputation c'est que ils ont
créé toutes les pièces qu'il faut pour
pouvoir ensuite créer n'importe quel
objet que tu as envie de créer c'est
fort après 32 heures de travail mon bébé
est finalement met à mal la version avec
les bonnes pièces et tout allait elle
envoie comme et après ça finit dans le
studio de mcfly karito espace un saturn
5 display c'est trop beau nahd alors la
fusée tu n'auras pas se mentir la mise
en valeur et totale quoi entre la cage
en verre la lumière rouge et la fosse
fumée extrêmement réaliste c'est un 9
sur 10
la lampe par est minable à côté alors
qu'elle pas mal elle m'a fait de l'oeil
de footing mahé 'robots' to work
j'ai mis mes robes au travail
[Musique]
non mais les gars arrêtez d'acheter des
lego aux ingénieurs là ils font
n'importe quoi faut laisser les gens
faire des éléphants avec des pièces
grise c'est très bien ouah mais ça tu
vois c'est vraiment stylé ça je suis
désolé je le mets dans mon décor je suis
heureux de malades clément la liesse
chute la foule en cu et tu m'achètes ça
bordel jégun merci clément produit est
certain qu être une machine à neige
automatisés
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu un mec autant
rentabiliser son achat de lego il en est
arrivé au stade de sa vie où il est
tellement fort en lego qu'il construit
avec des objets qu'ils devraient acheter
il veut un aspirateur il va pas sur la
fnac
il ouvre sa boîte à l'ego c'est trop
pour moi j'ai eu 30 ans aujourd'hui
voilà comment je les passais mes range
tes pièces non mais ça va pas rangement
les pièces là à temps je vais tomber les
numéros du gars du tout début
voir mon fils de 10 ans a gagné sa
première compétition de lego aujourd'hui
il avait trente minutes pour construire
quelque chose avec juste une boîte de
pièces standards assez intéressant sa
streak de concours
tout le monde a les mêmes goûts devant
lui qui va faire le meilleur truc juste
une énorme crevettes que j'ai design et
y construit ce week end bas pour nous
d'où tu que je te dise elle juste un
petit truc qui toi tu aurais pris cette
affaire que moi j'ai fait en un week end
messieurs il est temps d'aller au studio
et de découvrir ce que les gaumont
préparer et d'y ajouter notre touche
personnelle et 100 0 blagué
voilà taille du drap une immense il fait
combien de squeeze alors sous ce drap se
trouve une ville légaux je vois des
trucs regarder jusqu'où ça vous je vois
des trucs qui m'ont tellement alors déjà
on va découvrir cette ville ensemble
ensuite on a un premier mini jeu ils ont
caché des trucs dans la ville que je
vais devoir vous trouvez et après ça je
vous expliquer ce que moi je vais
construire parce que le principe des
lego évidemment c'est pas de contacts et
légaux pour qui t'amène un truc déjà
construit chez toi c'est de construire
toi même quelque chose alors découverte
el mex que je vois c'est que je vois là
c'est déjà assourdissant
mais ils sont fous mais y souffle
[Musique]
moi mais cette partie là elle est encore
plus fou mois à l'hôtel de ville
la densité de ce bâtiment sur ce post it
nous avons des endroits que nous allons
devoir retrouver dans la ville où est
charlie dans la vraie vie avec des lego
une mini figurine de squeeze +9 ce mec
c'est ça natsu et un gros casque de
gamers sur moi n'a tout n'est pas en
laisse
il est branché il est alimenté par une
batterie externe
les panneaux rebuild the world premier
panneau il est ici la tokyo tower gelé
vue directe elle est également fuji à
droite à toute cette plaque là c'est un
set 6-1 7 légaux spéciale japon et
dernier truc à trouver le canard six
briques
j'ai le canard six briques l'un des
premiers joueurs qu'ils ont
commercialisé c'était un canard en bois
dont une photo s'affiche maintenant à
l'écran et on image à ça ils ont fait un
petit canard comme ça fait à partir de
six briques différentes de lego théâtre
plein de combinaisons possibles rien
qu'avec ces six briques gens ça se
compte en millions dégagé plusieurs
avaient ce cargo
j'ai fait un escalier messieurs dames
laissez moi vous présenter les trains
les goûts vous l'avez vu cette vidéo
vous comprenez mon excitation il ya
plein de train ils vendent des rails etc
tu peux faire ton parcours de prien
d'accord mais ce drame aujourd'hui je
vais être ministre des transports je
vais construire le réseau ferré de cette
ville les goûts merci à tous et merci
tous les trains auront du retard tous
les jours et vous ferez des tweets et
vous savez quoi
on s'en bat les couilles pour ce faire
les gars j'ai des tas de raï d'accord
général qui tourne chez derek ils vont
tout droit
j'ai des aiguillages étape une dégager
tous les véhicules et tous les lego boy
qui traînent sur la route
[Musique]
messieurs dames les allées sont libérés
nous pouvons lancer la construction de
la voie ferrée nous aurons comme vous
pouvez le constater ici il y a une
immense ligne droite cette immense ligne
droite va bifurquer un moment donné ici
nous allons y poser un aiguillage le
train aura à leurs possibilités soit
d'aller tout droit soit de prendre cette
direction et de revenir par là bas en
gros c'est comme les vrais métro il ya
certains trains qui font le petit tour
et à certains trains qui desservent des
directions plus éloignés comme l'avenue
de l'hôtel ici très connu et la venue du
théâtre
on commence par cette grande ligne
droite là c'est le moment où il ya des
pilotes
une pièce flex elf l'ex maire discipline
aiguillages gaudin voit la nex énorme
je suis excité premier degré je vais
sauter mais avant une explosion méga
même pour la blague je pouvais pas
casser ça me ferait très mal au coeur
même pour la blague gens meurent dans
vie non même pour la blague je vais pas
tarder à le faire
[Musique]
oh mec l'emboîtage finale
amenez moi la loco là le monde n'est pas
prêt vous savez que j'adore les petits
bruitages et petit foc excellence est en
train de se connecter attendait la
surprise arrive
ne vous moquez pas déjà regarder là vous
êtes ému c'est normal regardez ce qu'il
ya sur cette appli c'est parti pour
tester le petit haut
ok je sais je sais que je sais qu'on a
vu les choses en trouant grand damne de
micasa dégage est celle là c'est tu vois
c'est la classique hausse et celles qui
traversent le temps c'est pas ces
nouveaux engins là complètement délirant
messieurs dames on y retourne merdes
mermet là sur l'essence agent est oui
ouais
qui a mené cet arbre ici chers habitants
je le sais le train est tout petit il ne
veut pas contenir tous les habitants de
la ville pas de souci pas de soucis ou
limitée d'un goût mais ce drame
inauguration du train grande ligne c'est
parti mon tour
[Musique]
j'ai dit ça j'ai dit ça j'ai réussi deux
itinéraires différents les aiguillages
fonctionne tout est nickel c'est
incroyable mec je suis vraiment content
d'avoir réussi à faire une voie ferrée
et en vrai je dois dire que le matériel
fonctionne extrêmement bien parce que
j'ai un peu fait je dirais pas que de la
mer mais il ya quand même des trucs pas
parfait quoi dans ce que j'ai fait et
pourtant ça a marché
nickel je suis particulièrement fier
d'avoir fait mon double aiguillages qui
permet de faire un train direct ou un
train qui fait un détour je suis très
content de ça bon en tout cas je veux
que la vidéo vous a plu merci beaucoup à
l'égout pour ce sponsoring ça me fait
trop plaisir
c'est un subtil cette activité manuelle
je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo
portez vous bien et légaux je vous rends
tout d'un kg est épatant
[Musique]